[Musica]
lo spazio e il tempo sono le due
dimensioni nelle quali si articola
l'esistenza dell'uomo e in questo
periodo di pandemia ci siamo detti
abbiamo vissuto un momento di
segregazione e oggi stiamo affrontando
un nuovo una nuova epoca che è una
riconquista di questi spazi
esistono tante forme di spazio tante
dimensioni di uno spazio interiore che è
uno spazio dove vi sono tutte le nostre
certezze
ciò che pensiamo su noi stessi ciò che
noi legittimiamo a noi stessi ea volte
queste certezze queste prospettive
limitano la nostra vera potenzialità
a volte ci sono cose che potremmo
raggiungere non immaginavo neanche
soltanto pensare
e allora il tema è riscoprire questa
dimensione interiore questa potere che
noi abbiamo di poter a di consigliere
atti in potenza ed è un discorso di
potere quindi è un discorso di
empowerment cioè di poter fissare delle
scelte e poter agire su di esse si
perché se nega per esempio ci dice bindi
cadetti b cioè rivendicate a te stesso
riapproprio di di quello che sei
senza pensare di essere altro cercando
di essere ciò che se di realizzare ciò
che è scritto in the ciò che sai nel tuo
corpo nella tua mente nel luogo in cui
ti trovi nel tempo nell'epoca in cui ti
trovi
eh sì perché a volte la realtà la
società al mondo ti porta via questa
legittimazione e ci sono fenomeni di
sunpower mente che possono essere
particolarmente mortificanti la persona
possono annichilire la persona la
possono disabilitare per esempio
pensiamo a un carcerato che fa appunto
l'esperienza di una contrario rapinano a
casa di un crimine che ha commesso
questo crimine deve portare a un
processo di riabilitazione ma spesse
volte questa esperienza si deduce un
discorso di repressione e allora questo
lo troviamo per esempio nelle
statistiche sulla depressione di queste
persone sull'elevatissimo tasso di
suicidi che è circa tra le 10 e le 100
volte superiore al tasso medio e al
tasso di recidiva che se chiaramente un
fallimento perché ben il 70 per cento
delle persone
un reato lo ri commettono nuovamente
cioè sette persone su dieci che hanno
già commesso reato commetto nuovamente
un reato e questo è un fallimento è un
fallimento per la società ed è un
fallimento della persona ma ci sono
situazioni molto simili di fallimento
sebbene all'interno di contesti che non
hanno limiti spaziali pensiamo ai sensi
senza fissa dimora e senza tetto che non
hanno problemi di limiti di spazio ma
non hanno un luogo dove stare in mezzo a
tutti ma lontano da tutti in un contesto
sociale ma esclusi da questo contesto
sociale così come avviene per esempio
nel caso dei persone che sono portatori
di disabilità mentale o fisica che sono
esclusi da per esempio il processo
creativo che è quello del lavoro perché
perché non sono in grado di remunerare
un capitale come i normodotati
e allora il tema è quello di emarginare
e portare escludere queste persone e poi
si verificano situazioni di periferie
esistenziali così come le ha definite
qualcuno si è una prospettiva di
spazzino e poi di anche uno spazio
economico lo spazio economico che oggi
noi potuti concepiamo come il
capitalismo cioè l'economia del capitale
remunerare un capitale appunto il valore
della persona la misuriamo in questi
termini se sei capace di retribuire un
capitale allora e valore altrimenti non
vale nulla e poi essere emarginato
questa è una menzogna è un'opera di
riduzionismo storico la realtà è che il
mercato è un contesto più grande e più
grande del capitale è un posto dove
possono vivere le persone dove c'è la
società dove c'è l'ambiente non mi
credete
esistono tante testimonianze di questo
per esempio nell impresa sociale
questo prototipo di impresa che pur
operando sul mercato opera per
beneficiare la persona arriva a
beneficiare quelle persone che soffrono
vivono estreni casi di emarginazione e
questa storia questa lezione me l'ha
insegnata luciana delle donne
questa imprenditrice fenomenale che
fonda a lecce un'impresa sociale dentro
un carcere un piccolo laboratorio
sartoriale dove vengono realizzati
borsette
proietti colorati utili ma futili e
questi prodotti vengono venduti sul
mercato perché c'è qualcuno che è
disposto a riconoscerne un valore ed è
disposto a pagare per comprarli e se
viene regolato un prezzo alla
evidentemente quel prodotto ha un valore
ha un valore anche all'azione della
donna che lo ha realizzato e quindi
quella persona ha un valore può
esprimere un valore e questo è l'esempio
dell'economia e inclusiva è una storia
meravigliosa che si traduce il risultato
fenomenale la recidiva delle donne che
fanno l'esperienza made in carcere è
prossima allo zero zero dal 70 per cento
a 0 questa cosa è fenomenale una storia
bellissima mi sono appassionato l'ho
studiata per 4 anni 4 anni di esperienza
di viaggi di interviste di contatto con
queste persone e l'ho pubblicata e poi
il giorno dopo mi sono guardato allo
specchio mi sono detto
e allora mai pubblicata tutto qui a roma
avremmo detto
embè la realtà è questa e che è come se
avessi scoperto il fuoco
nell'era preistorica non lo puoi
scrivere semplicemente sul mur e devi
dare fuoco al mondo e allora ho
conosciuto ho conosciuto lorenzo verso
di ciaccio che è un altro imprenditore
sociale è un ragazzo straordinario è uno
che sa che ha fondato la startup che si
chiama pedio se fa parlare i sordi al
cellulare
cioè far parlare i sordi al cellulare è
una cosa straordinaria
ci conosciamo parliamo e lui mi racconta
anche della sua esperienza di volontario
in sant'egidio questa organizzazione
fantastica che accoglie e aiuta
centinaia e migliaia di senzatetto
il problema è che lorenzo mi parla anche
di una mortificazione che vive anno dopo
anno perché anno dopo anno si
ripresentano sempre le stesse persone
sempre più abbrutiti esempi più
annichilite che entrano un circolo
vizioso da cui non riescono più a
riuscire e allora gli parlo del mio
modello dello studio che ho fatto di
made in carcere l'empowerment perché non
facciamo un modello di empowerment per
queste persone e lorenzo da bravo
imprenditore mi dici sì ma ci serve un
business
ci serve un business luca e allora
l'intuizione ci viene da un mio amico un
giorno ci manda questo pozza fece la
sensi ha chiamato l'ora di un giorno ha
detto preparatevi perché
chesta nascor patinata de prato da fare
in tutta la città noi più se manieri
siamo contente però non ci hanno più
chiamato che dovemo fa l'idea non era
male in effetti in germania l'hanno
applicata è avuto anche un discreto
seguito non soltanto in germania ma noi
abbiamo pensato ma se possiamo mandarci
o rovi gli ovini a prendersi cura del
verde pubblico
ma perché non possiamo per mandarci le
persone queste persone possono essere
riqualificate possono essere educate
possono essere possono ricevere una
proposta non posso aderire a questa
proposta di diventare giardinieri
giardini e di quello spazio di quel
verde pubblico di quello spazio urbano
degradato e dove loro stesse hanno
vissuto una situazione di degrado e
riqualificando quel tempo il terreno che
quello spazio quel quel contesto di
quali siano anche se stessi quindi un
processo maieutico in cui la
riqualificazione degli spazi e parlerà
una riqualificazione dello spazio
interiore di queste persone è l'idea ci
è piaciuta non solo a noi perché poi
l'abbiamo raccontata degli studenti
abbiamo fatto dei laboratori abbiamo
cominciato una serie di ragionamenti
sugli economics il modello di business e
l'idea piaceva e abbiamo coinvolto altri
altri amici e professionisti e
accademici
molti sono arrivati tanti se ne sono
andati ma noi abbiamo continuato abbiamo
fatto le prime sperimentazioni nei
giardini degli spazi pubblici e
addirittura siamo arrivati in un
terrazzo di una delle società di
consulenza finanziaria al consulenza
legale più importanti di roma che è così
siano del palazzo generali di fronte
piazza venezia
lo vedete in questa slide è uno dei
nostri collaboratori in un momento di
riposo si affaccia la ringhiera e indica
la piazza già proprio in fondo a piazza
a piazza venezia e indica una panchina e
ci dice vedete su quella panchina io ho
trascorso le settimane più terribili
della mia vita
non sapevo chi ero non sapevo cosa mi
sarei aspettato il giorno dopo se ci
sarei ancora stato il giorno dopo e
spesso guardavo questo terrazzo così
immaginando cosa potesse esserci un
posto tanto bello e mi sono ritrovato
oggi a guardare quella stessa panchina
da una diversa prospettiva
mi sono ritrovato oggi a guardare la mia
vita
la prospettiva e l'abbiamo capito che
l'italia aveva un potere si ridaje è
l'idea che abbiamo coniato il nome di
questa di questa startup ridaje perché
ridai e perché no camon again
all'americana perché non dagli e game
nori da ieri da lì è perché noi siamo
romani viviamo in un contesto nella
nostra società nella nostra comunità
rispondiamo a degli stimoli sociali
rispondiamo agli stimoli ambientali e
l'idea era quella di rispondere a queste
e questi stimoli
l'idea ci è piaciuta così tanto che
abbiamo organizzato un evento nella mia
università di origina luis abbiamo
organizzato questo evento che è andato
al di là di ogni nostra aspettativa
evento che così voglio in sintesi
condividere con voi la storia ci dice
che in teoria il sociale non corrisponde
al business quello che vogliamo
dimostrare esattamente il contrario
[Musica]
oggi parliamo di reinserire che si
chiama ritaglia in pratica cerchiamo di
trasformare i senzatetto in giardinieri
urbani che aveva già fatto con due
persone che cerchiamo un modo per farlo
scalabile ed avere un impatto sempre
ragione e questo è un modello
sostanzialmente di empowerment ovvero
che a che fare con lo sviluppo delle
persone e vogliamo dimostrare come il
mercato non è semplicemente un mercato
capitalista hanno un mercato che può
dare spazio alla dimensione umana e al
servizio dell'uomo nel team ci sono dei
ricercatori che studiano proprio questi
modelli sostenibili e l'idea è partita
dalle città perché senza tetto e
l'abbandono sono due cose comuni in
tutte le grandi città della cittadinanza
può segnalare tramite un'app che verrà
sviluppata nei prossimi mesi area su cui
vorrebbe richiedere l'intervento
ciascuna segnalazione è corrisponda una
definizione l'importo che dovrebbe
essere corrisposto per garantirgli
intervento e la manutenzione sull'area
ciascun cittadino può liberamente
contribuire una volta raggiunta la somma
necessaria per garantire per coprire i
costi dell'intervento
i nostri giardinieri interverranno e
faranno la fila di manutenzione quindi
tramite questa app collezioneremo alle
risorse economiche e di volta in volta
saranno necessarie per finanziare gli
interventi quindi quello che definì
finiremo appunto per essere scalabile
appunto un processo che sarà in
collaborazione con un'azienda in cui
ancora non posso fare il nome perché
stiamo per chiudere un accordo da
un'azienda che si occupa di formazione
quindi tutte le associazioni come
volontari sant'egidio che lavorano con
queste persone fanno una prima
scrematura ci segnaleranno dei nomi di
quelle che sono le persone che purtroppo
non possiamo non è una porta che vale
per tutti chiunque ha un problema una
dipendenza di qualsiasi tipo deve prima
risolverla deve prima risolvere la sua
patologia per poi poter iniziare a
lavoro quindi ci servono percorsi
diversi per quelle persone che sono più
vicini
basta che serve un aiuto più mirato
possiamo appunto pensare questa cosa qui
c'è un processo che è fatto da colloqui
sarà gestito da psicologi del lavoro non
tante iniziative che potrebbero
coinvolgere anche le pecore per
riqualificare il verde pubblico
noi abbiamo pensato che forse utilizzare
delle persone possa essere qualcosa di
libri a valore aggiunto
[Musica]
e l'evento ha avuto un successo
mediatico inaspettato siamo abbiamo
avuto una copertura da parte dei
principali testate giornalistiche sui
media
e allora ci siamo guardati in volto ci
siamo guardati negli occhi e ci siamo
detti che tutto sommato ridaje
daje daje si può fare e allora è una
questione di spazi interiori di spazi
esteriori e una questione di spazi
sociali di spazi economici che possono
essere vissuti in maniera diversa
e allora c'è un tempo c'è un tempo in
cui effettivamente abbiamo vissuto una
segregazione un tempo in cui e ora siamo
chiamati a vivere una riedificazione e
c'è un tempo che è un tempo diverso che
è il kairos e il tempo della scelta e la
scelta su come vogliamo vivere oggi
questi spazi
quando parliamo di una nuova società di
un nuovo mondo che possiamo costruire
dobbiamo decidere come lo vogliamo uno
spazio esclusivo escludente o uno spazio
inclusivo includente e quando parliamo
di inclusione parliamo includere tutti e
quindi includere anche me che sono
fragile e ho le mie fragilità le mie
piccolezze e ho le mie virtù e allora il
tema è valorizzare la persona
valorizzare anche me io voglio essere
valorizzato e voi
grazie
[Applauso]